[Música]
en primera plana
carlos cerrada
[Música]
bienvenidos en primera plana un programa
de radio france internacional y de
france 24 esta semana ya saben el día 8
de marzo es el día internacional de la
mujer y hoy queremos poner el foco sobre
el rol que han jugado las mujeres en
esta crisis sanitaria para ello me
acompañan en este estudio tres invitadas
alejandra meneses es analista de la ocde
especialista en políticas de género y
desarrollo bienvenida alejandra gracias
laura carpentier gov socióloga y experta
en cuestiones de género bienvenida laura
gracias y paula martínez infante
periodista independiente bienvenida para
hola hola k logra ser limitas el rol de
la mujer en la pandemia hoy nuestro
asunto aquí en primera plana
[Música]
el impacto que está teniendo la pandemia
en las mujeres es mayor a pesar de que
la prevalencia es más alta en hombres a
consecuencia de aspectos relacionados
con los roles de género y con la
precarización hacia las tareas de
sostenimiento de la vida que hace
mayoritariamente a las mujeres mujeres
que soportan una mayor carga de trabajos
precarios y economía sumergida de forma
muy visible en latinoamérica o están
mayoritariamente en la primera línea de
trabajos de cuidados y de atención
sociosanitaria el contexto pandémico ha
sacado a la luz el rol del trabajo de
cuidados que históricamente no han
tenido reconocimiento hoy en el programa
hablamos del rol de la mujer en la
pandemia que evidenciado el diagnóstico
de algunos planteamientos de la economía
feminista en cuanto a la importancia de
las relaciones humanas sobre las
productivas repasemos antes algunas
portadas de prensa revista time en su
edición de mujeres y pandemia se encarga
del reto para madres trabajadoras su
lucha y esa cuestión de los cuidados en
casa luego hablaremos de ello el
periódico de catalunya 2020 año del
liderazgo femenino dice el rotativo que
en mitad de la pandemia muchas mujer
de diversos sectores como la política o
la sanidad han destacado por su
liderazgo o'globo en brasil
kobe y ellas las mujeres dice el
rotativo tienen un día a día mucho más
impactado por la pandemia bueno lo
primero alejandra si vamos a hacer una
ronda en general qué rol han jugado las
pandemia han jugado a las mujeres
durante esta pandemia que destacar y es
desde ese papel
primero que todo las mujeres en américa
latina y el caribe siempre han
desempeñado un rol importante en la
economía solo que hasta hace muy poco
tiempo este rol no ha sido reconocido ni
valorizado por las personas ni por los
formadores de formuladores de políticas
públicas en estos gobiernos las mujeres
en américa latina aproximadamente
dedican tres veces más del tiempo en
tareas domésticas y en cuidados no
remunerados que los hombres en américa
latina y el caribe esta cifra es muy
importante porque revela que las mujeres
en américa latina' tienen este rol de
madres de cuidadoras principales en los
hogares y además de esto revela que
debido a los roles de género
tradicionales que están enraizados en la
cultura de américa latina y el caribe no
les permite dedicar su tiempo libre a
otras actividades productivas a otras
actividades
en participación política u otras
actividades laborales que las permitan
tener una independencia económica
este es un rol muy importante que
siempre han cumplido las mujeres y que
ahora se ha visibilizado durante la
pandemia
otro error muy importante de las mujeres
es que son mayoritarias en el sistema de
cuidados aproximadamente el 80% de las
personas que trabajan en el sector
doméstico en américa latina y el caribe
son mujeres esto quiere decir que en la
mayoría de estas mujeres se van a
encontrar primero en la casa teniendo un
rol de madres de cuidadoras y segundo
cuando van a trabajar van a tener
también ese mismo rol que ahora con la
pandemia se ha agudizado y han tenido
una carga doméstica y una carga
emocional mucho más grande vamos a
repartir juego el aura que paga de qué
rol qué destacarías del rol de las
mujeres en esta pandemia
además de lo que dijo alejandra y
agregaría también que estuvieron en la
primera línea del frente también
directamente en contacto con el
coronavirus no porque las mujeres
presenta casi el 78 75 por ciento de la
población de los los y las trabajadores
en el sector de la salud entonces
estuvieron muy expuestas al virus y
además hay que tomar en cuenta que ellas
perciben sueldos en promedio de 25 por
ciento 25 por ciento más bajos que los
de los hombres en el mismo sector
entonces es como una doble pena y más
allá de eso mayor exposición y menor
atribuye exacto exacto y hubo una una
doble pena también porque en particular
al comer
en los primeros durante los primeros
meses de la pandemia también cuando
contrajeron el virus muchas de ellas
fueron tratadas como chivos expiatorios
no fueron marginalidad marginalizadas
echadas a la calle por los dueños las
enfermeras entonces estuvieron como
hueste este doble estuvieron en primera
línea del frente y además sufrieron pues
consecuencias por esta sobreexposición
no antes una doble pena también
haciendo un resumen de lo que están
diciendo a mí mis compañeras acá es
cierto que hay un doble juego digamos el
rol de la mujer ha sido y siempre ha
sido el pilar de la sociedad no hay que
olvidarlo soy de la pandemia puso en
evidencia efectivamente que ese rol que
es fundamental en todas las sociedades
fue fragilizado por la desigualdad de
género que es una pandemia también en
américa latina el caribe y en otros
lados del mundo también y por otro lado
quisiera agregar que las mujeres ir
viene siendo han sido el chivo
expiatorio y al mismo tiempo víctimas
entre comillas de esta situación han
sido el motor también de un montón de
iniciativas para poder salir de la
situación grave y que no hay que olvidar
o que no se ha acabado todavía esto se
veremos más adelante como de alguna
manera si bien esta idea del rol de
víctimas entre comillas aunque no me
gusta esa palabra también han sido el
motor y siguen siendo el motor de toda
la situación de cómo salir de la
situación infra en la cual nos
encontramos millones de mujeres trabajan
en la informalidad en américa latina o
en empleos precarios en contacto con la
población para ellas es imposible
decidir entre distancia social y un
sueldo otras muchas han dejado de plano
su empleo marcando un retroceso
importante de la
presencia de las mujeres en el mercado
laboral muchas de ellas se han tenido
que quedar en casa con niños que no han
podido ir a la escuela durante meses
cómo reparar esta brecha que aún se ha
acrecentado más en que de por si una
región tan desigualdad como américa
latina' alejandra bueno primero que todo
yo creo que es importante contextualizar
la situación socioeconómica que se vive
actualmente en américa latina y el
caribe debido a la pandemia
según informes de organizaciones
internacionales y américa latina y el
caribe fue la región en desarrollo y
emergentes más afectada por la crisis de
la pandemia con respecto al crecimiento
del producto interno bruto
aproximadamente del 7 al 9 por ciento
del producto interno bruto cayó en
américa latina'
debido a esta crisis sanitaria además de
esto el 10 por ciento de la desocupación
laboral aumentó el año pasado en américa
latina' y 22% de la tasa de desocupación
de las mujeres está prevista para el
periodo del 2020 al 2021 estas
consecuencias del sistema macroeconómico
de américa latina' va a afectar
fundamentalmente a las mujeres y a los
grupos vulnerables que se encuentran
dentro del grupo de las mujeres porque
normalmente en el discurso siempre
hablamos de las mujeres en general pero
en américa latina tenemos que tener en
cuenta que va a haber grupos vulnerables
como las mujeres que trabajan en el
sector informal como las mujeres que
tienen menores ingresos las mujeres
migrantes que ahora hay una explosión
debido a la crisis humanitaria que se
vive en ciertos países de américa latina
además de esto las mujeres
afrodescendientes las mujeres indígenas
vemos que en el caso de la pandemia
estas mujeres fueron las más afectadas y
las más vulnerables
durante la pandemia entonces que se
podría hacer en américa latina' para
revertir esta situación que además según
estimaciones
aproximadamente 10 años de retroceso se
va a encontrar en américa latina con
respecto a la situación laboral de las
mujeres lo que los gobiernos tienen que
hacer básicamente ahora es tener una
nueva visión del sistema de cuidados y
reinventar el pacto social en américa
latina'
una de las medidas que podrían tomar los
gobiernos en américa latina' sería de re
conceptualizar el concepto de cuidados
porque actualmente se está viendo como
un gasto social y no como una inversión
a mediano y largo plazo en las economías
de américa latina y el caribe vamos a
centrarnos en este concepto que decía
alejandra de cuidados me quiero quedar
ahí porque hemos hablado cuantas veces
durante esta crisis de la importancia de
los de los cuidados sin embargo el nuevo
foco en la importancia de los cuidados
no necesariamente ha conllevado al menos
hasta ahora un reconocimiento
institucional del carácter feminizado de
éstos porque hasta ahora no se ha
reconocido los cuidados laura porque en
su gran mayoría era un trabajo de
mujeres y se consideraba como algo
natural en realidad no se considera
realmente como un trabajo no sino como
el valor de las obligaciones inherentes
al hecho de ser mujer
exactamente exactamente y agregaría algo
también es importante tomar en cuenta el
tema de la representación política de
las mujeres hasta hace poco en realidad
su representación era deficitaria lo
sigue siendo pero ni siquiera llegaban a
tener un porcentaje suficiente como para
imponer sus problemáticas las
problemáticas que afectan en particular
en las mujeres en la agenda política
entonces obviamente el asunto también de
la paridad es muy importante no es
suficiente no es automático pero es
sumamente importante no la economía de
consumo se ha ralentizado cuando no se
ha paralizado por completo y ha quedado
en un segundo plano ante la necesidad de
priorizar el cuidado del que hablamos
del cuidado de las personas ante todo
actividad tradicionalmente llevada a
cabo por mujeres como comentábamos creen
que esto puede tener paola una un
reflejo en la reconstrucción post crisis
este reflejo de tener en cuenta
y valorar pero absolutamente libro que
todo todo está enlazado el problema aquí
el tema de la paridad y la desigualdad
de género ya lo decía anteriormente es
una pandemia existen américa latina
desde siglos ok y ya se ha venido
trabajando en décadas posteriores
anteriores perdón a este abrir estos
caminos para poder llegar a esta paridad
el problema que aquí no hay
transversalidad todos los caminos se han
abierto de manera separada cierto veamos
acá hagamos una ley para esto acabo dale
para otro hay mujeres que han ocupado
puestos importantes que siguen ocupando
puestos importantes en política por
ejemplo américa latina sin embargo de
este fondo el problema de fondo es como
también los hombres participan en la
aceptación de este de este rol que va a
jugar la mujer más adelante hago
referencia al ministro de hacienda de
chile que dijo que la pandemia no
podemos seguir de pandemias y en el rol
de las mujeres
ok también pero siempre nos damos cuenta
que eso queda en las palabras siempre se
prometen grandes cosas pero en las
políticas estatales en las políticas de
cada gobierno el hecho de aplicar esa
política y de realmente incorporar a la
mujer en el juego económico en él
o político ahí cuando el lugar nos está
dando lo sabemos hoy día las mujeres
están en primera línea en todos los
aspectos como lo decían mis compañeras
10 por ciento y en 10 por ciento del
mundo laboral también eso que
considerarlo hoy día y como como hoy día
las nuevas políticas económicas el
sistema capitalista que es fuertísimo en
américa latina una profunda desigualdad
social y también que hoy día da cuenta
de la desigualdad de género las mujeres
van a poder debieran tener su lugar debe
entender su lugar pero eso todo va a
acabar va a darse si los hombres entre
comillas esto no se hace sin el hombre
da ese lugar efectivamente a la mujer
hagamos en este punto una breve pausa y
a la vuelta les quiero preguntar por
aspectos que han marcado a la mujer
durante la pandemia algunos oscuros como
la violencia de género y otros cargados
de luz como la labor de investigadoras
que han estado en primera línea y de esa
forma de gestionar la pandemia de
algunas líderes mundiales que se ha
puesto como ejemplo de que pueden
existir otras formas de gestionar más
empáticas con mirada femenina a las que
quizás la inercia histórica ha
ninguneado siempre hasta ahora
[Música]
el gobierno de marruecos prepara un
proyecto de ley para la despenalización
del uso terapéutico del cannabis este
país es el mayor productor de cannabis
del mundo y el debate sobre la
despenalización tiene una larga
trayectoria esta planta se cultiva desde
hace siglos de forma ilegal en las
montañas del rif una de las regiones más
empobrecidas del país allí habría más de
50 mil áreas de cultivo y más de 100.000
personas que dependerían exclusivamente
de las plantaciones y según el estudio
del proyecto leyes en legalizar la
industria cannábica podría repercutir
muy positivamente la economía del país
por lo que la mayoría de formaciones
políticas se muestran a favor a
excepción eso sí del partido de la
justicia y el desarrollo único partido
islamista legal en marruecos y que
ostenta ahora mismo en la presidencia
del gobierno no obstante estos
islamistas no tienen mayoría
parlamentaria ni los ministerios más
relevantes como es el caso del interior
artífice de este proyecto ley de llegar
al parlamento por tanto podría ser
aprobado con facilidad y por otra parte
en la legalización del uso terapéutico
del cannabis tiene buena aceptación
social pero los agricultores del reef
lamentan que nos haya contado con ellos
para elaborar el proyecto ley
[Música]
desde noviembre pasado el senado
mexicano aprobó las leyes para regular
el uso adulto de la cannabis y las turnó
a la cámara de diputados para su
ratificación luego de más de tres meses
de desacuerdos los diputados apenas se
alistan para discutir las modificaciones
que harán a estas normas que entre otras
cosas permiten la posición de hasta 28
gramos de marihuana para consumo
personal la siembra y cultivo de hasta 6
plantas por casa habitación y crean el
instituto mexicano de cannabis el
organismo que se encargará de otorgar
las licencias para todo el proceso desde
la siembra de cultivo hasta la
producción distribución comercialización
y consumo de cannabis mientras tanto
afuera del senado continúa el plantón de
colectivos cannábicos que exigen ya la
aprobación de esta legislación y piden
cambiar el enfoque comercial por uno más
dirigido a los derechos humanos la
prórroga que concedió la suprema corte
de justicia para que quede lista esta
legislación pensé el próximo 30 de abril
[Música]
con la reciente legalización de la
marihuana en el estado de virginia ahora
son 16 estados en la unión americana que
permiten el uso recreacional de la
marihuana para adultos
la medida en virginia sin embargo solo
entrará en vigor a partir del 2024 los
otros estados que recientemente
legalizaron su uso recreacional y
medicinal son nueva jersey dakota del
sur y arizona es de resaltar que en 36
estados ya es permitido el uso medicinal
de la marihuana lo que las pasadas
elecciones de noviembre revelaron es que
este tema de la legalización es de
interés bipartidista en estados unidos y
de hecho jackson líder de los demócratas
en el senado ha dicho que la
legalización de la marihuana a nivel
federal es una prioridad en la agenda
del partido
hoy los arrestos por uso
comercialización y posesión de la
marihuana son la mitad de los arrestos
por crímenes relacionados con drogas
[Música]
seguimos en primera plana había hablando
del rol de la mujer en latinoamérica y
también en el mundo durante esta
pandemia acompañados de alejandra
meneses es analista de la ocde laura
carpentier gov doctora en sociología y
paula martínez infante periodista
independiente antes de pasar a otros
temas el caso de las empleadas
domésticas que es muy específico en la
región en latinoamérica un grupo
vulnerable cuyos derechos no ha sido
para nada garantizados durante este
tiempo
laura no hoy no es nada nuevo no ya ya
desde
siglos no ha sido un grupo cuyos
derechos ha sido han sido muy muy
vulnerados a pesar de los avances
legislativos que se consiguieron en los
últimos años sigue siendo un sector muy
informal cuyos derechos humanos están
siendo violados a diario no entonces
cuando llegó la pandemia hubo despidos
masivos sin que tengan derecho bueno si
tenían derecho o no pero sin que
perciban sus beneficios los empleadores
en muchos casos no les pagaron sus
beneficios ni siquiera su último sueldo
en muchos casos este es un grupo también
cuya cuyo acceso al seguro social es muy
muy difícil no no se garantiza para nada
entonces eso ha tenido consecuencias en
su capacidad de tener acceso a la
atención médica durante la pandemia otro
aspecto es que la mayoría no tuvo acceso
a los bonos estatales o sea realmente se
encontraron sin ninguna fuente de
ingreso durante la pandemia por ejemplo
en perú hicieran un estudio
del 85 no tuvo acceso a los bonos
estatales y también para las que no
perdieron el trabajo están expuestas a
una sobreexplotación terrible no la
carga laboral de por sí aumentó porque
las medidas de higiene están más
estrictas también por el cierre de las
escuelas entonces la atención a los
niños y las niñas fue mayor saber les
exigió un mayor trabajo y para terminar
ahora en particular las que trabajan
cama adentro
están casi como secuestradas no en casa
del empleador les dicen como no puede
salir porque tomando como pretexto el
riesgo de que bueno vuelvan a la casa
trayendo el virus y les no que puede
salir pero vas a tener que hacerte la
prueba no la prueba médica del cobi pero
hay que tomar en cuenta que por ejemplo
en perú el juez el costo de la prueba es
casi la casi la mitad de un sueldo
mínimo que no les está garantizado no a
ellas tampoco en chile por ejemplo el
sindicato de trabajadoras domésticas de
casas particulares esta cuna está que se
llama cuida a quien te cuida
exigen efectivamente porque hubo 14.000
de despidos así sin ningún seguro de
cesantía detrás que después lucharon y
en septiembre obtuvieron seguros de
sancti a 120.000 mujeres estar en el
mercado negro informal que no tienen
ninguna posibilidad de obtener ningún
seguro al mismo tiempo que hoy día están
exigiendo que chile y otros gobiernos
puedan ratificar los convenios de la
agresión y tercer el trabajo que el 189
190 que protege los trabajadores
domésticas por una parte y también que
protege y sanciona el acoso sexual y el
abuso en el mundo del trabajo porque es
un sector que es fundamental que es el
pilar también en muchas casas en américa
latina'
sin embargo un sector que está
completamente mirado con un desprecio
absoluto en la cual las mujeres han
tenido que salir a la calle a manifestar
y siguen haciéndolo para poder ser
consideradas como una fuerza de trabajo
que necesita también estar resguardada
por sus derechos vamos a avanzar con
otros puntos que nos interesan sobre el
rol de la mujer en durante esta durante
toda esta crisis sanitaria la pandemia
también ha producido ese efecto
devastador de la violencia de género
obligar a que muchas mujeres tuviesen
que pasar tiempo en confinamiento con
sus maltratado
alejandra las administraciones los
poderes hasta qué punto han tenido en
cuenta
esta realidad cuando tomaban sus
decisiones han activado vías para
neutralizar esa violencia al mismo
tiempo que decretaba en estos
confinamientos primero que todo me
gustaría contextualizar la situación de
la violencia de género que se vive
actualmente en américa latina y que
siempre se ha vivido es otra pandemia
silenciosa que viven día a día todas las
mujeres latinoamericanas
según nuestras estimaciones
aproximadamente el 27 por ciento de las
mujeres en américa latina y el caribe
han experimentado violencia física o
sexual por parte de su pareja y durante
el confinamiento y durante la crisis
sanitaria estas cifras van a aumentar de
manera significativa además de esto no
solamente existe la violencia física o
sexual en américa latina sino que
también existen los feminicidios que es
el asesinato de las mujeres solamente
por el hecho de ser mujeres en el año
2019 se estimaba que aproximadamente 3
mil 800 mujeres fueron asesinadas en
américa latina y el caribe por mano de
sus agresores
américa latina' solamente cuenta con
algunas legislaciones con respecto al
feminicidio 18 países actualmente tienen
legislación con respecto a esto de los
33 países de américa latina y el caribe
quiere decir que materia legislativa y
de marcos jurídicos las mujeres todavía
no están siendo protegidas por los
gobiernos durante estas restricciones de
confinamiento de restricciones también
de la movilidad local y también entre
regiones en américa latina y el caribe
en algunos casos por ejemplo en colombia
se vio un aumento del 51 por ciento de
los casos de violencia intrafamiliar
esta cifra es muy preocupante no
solamente en colombia sino también en
otros países en américa latina que
vivieron la misma experiencia sin
embargo hay algunas pistas y algunas
iniciativas que fueron lanzadas por los
gobiernos por ejemplo aproximadamente
177 de las medidas que se tomaron en
américa latina y el caribe para encarar
la crisis sanitaria
dedicadas a combatir la violencia
doméstica y de género américa latina y
el caribe por ejemplo tenemos el caso de
argentina donde se decretó la excepción
de cuarentena obligatoria para las
mujeres y personas lgtb y que estaban
experimentando situaciones de violencia
y que se encontraba en una situación
vulnerable
siguiendo mismo caso de argentina el
ministerio de mujeres género y
diversidad e hizo un trabajo de
coordinación con la policía con la
justicia y con el sector privado para
que se abrieran refugios en los hoteles
para poder acoger a las mujeres víctimas
y sobrevivientes de violencia de género
por otra parte hubo políticas públicas
sumamente dañinas para las mujeres por
ejemplo la alcaldía de bogotá tomó como
decisión condicionar las ayudas
monetarias a los hogares de bajos
recursos al requisito de que no hubiese
denuncia por violencia doméstica dentro
de dicho hogar obviamente eso fue una
medida disuasiva no las mujeres que
están sufriendo violencia por miedo
su única fuente de ingresos durante la
pandemia no ayuda a denunciar no podía
porque el riesgo era perder esta fuente
de ingreso no vamos a ir saltando de
tema en tema porque me quedan muchas
cuestiones por abordar y muy pocos
minutos muchos se ha abordado vamos
hablar del liderazgo femenino porque
mucho se ha hablado de la gestión de la
pandemia de ciertas líderes mundiales
pongamos por ejemplo la primera ministra
de nueva zelanda jacinta a dern qué
valores reconocen al liderazgo femenino
en una situación de crisis sanitaria y
social como la que estamos viviendo
creen que esta visión más empática del
liderazgo femenino puede poner en valor
lo que es cierto bien social totalmente
totalmente de hecho el año pasado
recuerden las revistas forbes sacó un
listado de las siete mujeres que hoy día
están al mando del de ciertos países y
era donde mejor la crisis había se había
gestionado a los países nórdicos
dinamarca noruega
la primera ministra angela merkel
también después bueno han sido
criticados por diferentes aspectos
porque la pandemia perdura no hay que
olvidarlo también alargó tan a largo
término también las cosas funcionan de
manera diferente están un poco tanto
terreno cómo hacer las cosas diferente
mente sin embargo yo pienso que
efectivamente las mujeres son las que
tienen la batuta en alguna manera porque
tienen ese doble estándar de una manera
de pensar efectivamente en el mundo
laboral en el mundo del trabajo en la
política con mujeres supercapaces
competen súper competentes para poder
llevar a cabo política para poder salir
de esta crisis y por otro lado está lo
que llaman la doble carga mental que
igual si bien es cierto es una
problemática saben lo que pasa en las
casas saben ponerse también en lugar del
otro entonces finalmente yo pienso que
hoy día esos referentes femeninos que
han habido en ciertos lugares en ciertos
países efectivamente se dan cuenta de
este aspecto muy positivo como como una
digamos una apertura una esperanza de
que las mujeres tienen que estar ahí
para poder sacar a la gente de la
pandemia de alguna manera hemos hablado
antes de las cargas
alejandra y otras realidades como por
ejemplo el teletrabajo que han puesto la
cob y no sé si esto puede beneficiar
también algunos públicos como por
ejemplo las madres solteras no sé si
algunos de los mecanismos que
activado durante esta crisis también
podemos encontrar ciertos beneficios
hacia la mujer
y bueno con respecto al teletrabajo
primero hay que decir que eso beneficia
un porcentaje muy pequeño de la
población en américa latina'
aproximadamente el 23 por ciento de la
población américa latina puede hacer
teletrabajo además de esto hay que
destacar que en américa latina' las
mujeres tienen hay un existe una brecha
digital las mujeres no tienen el mismo
acceso a la tecnología que los hombres
además de esto las mujeres tampoco
participan de manera igualitaria en los
programas de educación como de
ingeniería matemática ciencia que los
cuales van a tener una repercusión
importante luego en la toma de
decisiones y en los proyectos de
digitalización en américa latina y el
caribe creo que o no mujeres están
llevando a cabo ahora una iniciativa con
diversos gobiernos en américa latina y
el sector privado para poder tener esta
un paquete digital que pueda tener una
computadora por una tablet un teléfono
celular interrumpe pero la brecha
digital tiene que ver con los trabajos
que necesita en ese trabajo digital y
ellos sabemos que las mujeres en américa
latina' ocupan trabajos que no necesitan
justamente tener un computador ordenador
en casa ellas están destinadas a
trabajos de comercio trabajo informales
pequeñas ventas etcétera entonces la
brecha digital si bien es un problema
importante que hay que suplir hay que
mejorar todo todo el sector económico en
la cual la mujer están las más afectadas
el sector informal donde no necesitan
usar está digital yo pienso que hay que
realmente poner el énfasis acá
en la cuestión del hambre la fao hoy día
señala que américa latina y el caribe el
89 por ciento de la población está
sufriendo de hambre y que no son las
primeras afectadas son las madres que
tienen que parar la olla es presión
chilena y eso también hay que
considerarlo común como un elemento
importante porque el teletrabajo es
importante pero sabemos que la mayoría
del porcentaje del trabajo que ocupa la
mujer hoy día que ya está
vulnerabilizados y fragilizado no es el
trabajo digital
algún apunte más laureada sí quizás para
terminar si me permites o sea también
hay que tomar en cuenta que para el
porcentaje que no es la mayoría pero que
si está en condiciones de bueno de
espera en teletrabajo hay que tomar en
cuenta que muchos estudios demostraron
que en la ausencia de corte entre la
doble jornada de las mujeres no la
jornada de trabajo asalariado y la
jornada del trabajo doméstico esta
ausencia de corte la fusión de ambas
jornadas es un factor muy propicio al
bern out no entonces hay que tomar
también eso en cuenta
no sé si quería más pero muchísimas
gracias por haberme acompañado en este
programa que hemos dedicado a analizar
el rol que juegan las mujeres que han
jugado durante esta crisis sanitaria y
esperemos que se produzcan avances en lo
que se llaman los programas de
recuperación algo de lo que vamos a
hablar mucho a partir de ahora
muchísimas gracias hasta la próxima
semana aquí en primera plana
[Música]